Christopher Clark is the attorney who is dealing
with the case now for several years, and it
is describing the outlines of what happening,
and that is the agreement of hunter Biden
and the attorney general's office of the district
of Delaware and it is my understanding that
the five-year investigation into hunter Biden
is resolved, and this is the key sentence.
My understanding that the five-year investigation
into hunter is resolved and he is going to
take responsibility for two misdemeanors for
filing tax agreements when due, and a plea
agreement, and the firearm charge is due to
a diversion agreement, and subject to plea
agreement and not filed by the government.
This is also what he says about hunter. Hunter
believes it is important the take responsibility
for
[10:01:27 AM]
the take responsibility for these mistakes
he made in a period of turmoil and addiction
in his life, and he is looking forward to
continuing the recovery in his life, and the
key operative parts of the statement are that
at least in their discussions with the prosecutors
in the U.S. Attorney's office and again this
is U.S. Attorney David Weiss by Donald Trump
appointed to oversee this investigation, and
this deal that resolves the investigation
according to hunter Biden's attorneys believes
this resolves everything, and really, that
is an important part of this plea agreement,
because this investigation as we have talked
about spanning five years and three attorneys
general have looked at a lot of information
including his dealings with Ukraine and things
that Republicans are not going to let go of,
and they believe more
[10:02:28 AM]
go of, and they believe more investigation
needs to be done, and even if they believe
this investigation is done, criminal investigation
with the attorney's office in Delaware is
over, and maybe they face more questions from
house Republicans who are not quite done with
this yet. Kate and John.
>> Evan, stick with us, and continue to get
more sources and statements coming in with
the statements and reaction coming over from
the white house. Arlette Seanez, we are hearing
from the president and first lady now?
>> Yes, the first reaction came in moments
ago from the white house as the Bidens are
continuing to offer their support to their
son hunter Biden, and we want to hear from
Ian sands saying that the president and first
lady love their son as he continues to rebuild
his life. He added that we will have no further
comments. The president is out traveling in
California and we expect to see him in the
4:00 P.M. Eastern hour where he is going to
have a speech there, and we will see if he
has any more comments on this news about his
son.
[10:03:33 AM]
news about his son. But the news from the
white house tracks with what we have repeatedly
been hearing from the Biden couple relating
to their son hunter. They have long stressed
their support for him, and really president
Biden has sought to keep him close to him
here at the white house. He is a frequent
presence over the course of the past few years
and family events and coming for official
events and out mingling with the crowd as
they hosted the annual Easter egg roll in
April and he travelled with the president
over to Ireland as they went to look into
the familial roots into the long-standing
love of the president's love of the country
of Ireland as well, but it is coming as the
white house has tried to refrain weighing
into any matters of the justice department
investigation into hunter Biden and they have
gone to great lengths to make sure it is an
independent investigation, but officials here
at the white house and the president's personal
attorney Bob bower has been keeping tabs on
the case, and Bob bower has been speaking
with the legal team of hunter
[10:04:34 AM]
with the legal team of hunter Biden to get
updates on where things stood, but the Biden
family have been navigating the situation
for years. He was a frequent target for Republicans
and former president Donald Trump back in
the 2020 campaign, and Biden often and repeatedly
would defend his son hunter, including his
addiction issues that he had faced, but now
today as the federal charges are coming to
light as hunter Biden is pleading guilty to
two of the federal charges the president and
first lady are maintaining the unwavering
support for the son in their statement, and
we will see if there is any further reaction
through the course of the day.
>> Again, we will see the president later
today, and they say this is the only statement
that we will have today, but I will be surprised
if we don't hear directly from the president
today. But the attorney for hunter Biden says
that it is my understanding that the five-year
investigation into hunter is resolved and
one place that may not share that sentiment
is among the Republicans on capitol hill,
and we will go there.
[10:05:35 AM]
hill, and we will go there. Our Manu raja
is standing by. Any reaction?
>> We have not heard from chairman Kevin Mccarthy
or any of the key committees investigating
hunter Biden or any of the other members,
but there are some members of the rank and
file quick to criticize this plea deal and
criticizing the attorney general such as Darrell
Issa called it a cover-up, and Marjorie Taylor
Greene who is a close ally of the speaker
of the house Kevin Mccarthy said it is a quote
stunt, and called the justice department pathetic,
and congressman Bob good, another member of
the freedom caucus criticizing this as well.
What you can expect from the house Republicans
in the weeks ahead is to essentially
[10:06:36 AM]
ahead is to essentially investigate the investigators
and figure out why this U.S. Attorney did
not pursue, or file charges or in what how
he handled those questions about hunter Biden's
overseas business dealings that did not lead
to any federal charges here. There's expected
to be a lot of criticism and this is an attorney
who is a holdover from the trump administration,
and still not, and the Republicans are indicating
that this is all part of their narrative that
Democrats somehow get a pass, and Republicans
do not. We will see if the facts bear it out.
That is the political argument going forward
and expect the speaker of the house to repeat
those comments, and now, expect the speaker
of the house, and the judiciary committee
to say the same, and this plea deal reached
after an exhaustive investigation leading
to this plea deal is not going to be much
for the satisfaction here
[10:07:36 AM]
much for the satisfaction here on capitol
hill among the house Republicans who have
made this a central investigation look into
hunter Biden as well as to any ties to the
president, and they expect that to be the
focus in the weeks ahead, guys.
>> Manu raja, thank you very much. And keep
us posted as to what else you should hear,
and we should note that this is a trump-appointed
U.S. Attorney who is a holdover here who struck
this plea deal.
>> So you that. And over to Kara Scannell
outside of the court who has been tracking
this with us. And Kara, you have fresh reporting
with this deal will bring what punishment?
>> Yes, so our understanding according to
the sources is that the U.S. Attorney's office
here has agreed as part of the plea agreement
to recommend to the judge that hunter Biden
serve no prison time and he be put on probation
for a set period of time and that is about
24 months. We have not seen the details yet,
but the court findings indicate that the details
including this plea agreement
[10:08:38 AM]
including this plea agreement deal be placed
before the court when it is set, and we have
learned that he is not going to be facing
any jail time or prison time as a result of
pleading guilty to the two tax-related misdemeanors
and it is drawing a reaction from former president
trump who is posting that this is a deal that
equates to a mere traffic ticket, and that
is something that M Manu raja is hearing up
on the hill. And so, we will be hearing of
when that is going T O allow cute
[10:09:41 AM]
O allow cute what went wrong with that and
so, we will see if that is dropped if he meets
a certain period of time with that deal.
>> So probation. Okay. Let's talk about what
that means in terms of the this deal and where
it sits. Joining us is our legal analyst Elie
Honig, and Paula Reid is somewhere with us.
And Elie, let me make one thing clear, that
president Biden has been saying that he did
not think that hunter Biden did anything wrong,
but this is an admission that he did something
wrong.
>> Yes.
>> Hunter Biden is saying that he broke the
law, and he is agreeing to probation, and
talk to me about that.
>> Probation means no prison as long as you
comply with all of the conditions, and there
is going to be a specific set of conditions
on the probation, and varies case to case,
and first of all, no further crimes while
[10:10:42 AM]
of all, no further crimes while you are on
probation, and typically in a case like this,
a condition like this is drug treatment and
regular drug testing and weekly, monthly,
daily, and you have to report into the probation
officer week, day, var ris based on the individual.
I think that there is another important part
of time and the politics about this. I have
said it before that the fact that it took
five years is outrageous, and inexplicable
dating back to 2018. Thinking of the nature
of the channels for two full years, 2018 through
the the end of 2020 this is handled by Donald
Trump